♪♪
It's mommy's first day back
to the office this week.
I don't want you to go,
don't go.
♪♪
♪ They're not brave like you ♪
♪ They're too scared to do ♪
♪ Anything that's different ♪
♪ Anything that's new ♪
Ta-da
Wow
Uh, is it for your
golf trophies?
It's for you.
They're turning your
book into a movie.
I wish I felt less
itchy about it.
Mhm-mhm, make the most of this.
I don't understand why you guys
aren't answering any
of my questions.
You're not saying anything.
There's a lot of
photos missing.
I ate them.
What?
I got married without
even knowing
what he would be like.
You could return him.
And what's the reason for
returning your husband?
Where to start?
♪ Gather 'round, here's how to
get what you want ♪
♪ Introduce a new religion
of feeling like a boss ♪
Oh my God
Who would do this?
I'm a ghost.
It's annoying that you're
actually kind of attractive.
You want to take
revenge like a man?
You gotta dress like one.
Or not take revenge,
is the other option.
I met someone.
Oh my God, is he married?
No
Do you want dessert?
I will do bedtime.
That's a risky move,
promising bedtime.
[screams]
♪♪
I really don't know how
you ladies do it.
Mhm, witchcraft mainly.
If I am a ghost...
Why am I still getting cramps?